hey guys miss peregrine's home for
peculiar children is now out and if you
have been a long time watcher
you know that miss peregrine's home for
peculiar children is pretty much my
favorite book I said it was my favorite
book in 2 CUNY's now so it is my
favorite book and I am very very happy
to announce that I got the brilliant
opportunity to go and interview the
actors within this Tim Burton movie I
was like oh I got to sit down with asa
butterfield Ella Pernell and Finley
Macmillan just to chat to them about the
film and the differences between the
book and the movie because I know there
was some controversy around that you can
see the interview thank you put it in a
separate video for you so you don't have
to listen to me ramble cuz that's
definitely all I'm gonna do in this
video so miss peregrine's home for
peculiar children is all about a group
of children who have peculiarities it's
interesting because basically these are
all kind of supernatural powers however
it's not kind of in your typical DC
Marvel style their kind of powers that
you might not really want would you want
to be a host to be living inside of your
mouth that could sting new people
whenever you speak to them I don't know
maybe you do want that but I personally
did not want some B's when I was a kid
however I did want the peculiarity to
make plants grow I wanted to poison ivy
so that's in the film anyway off topic
it's a very different approach to
showing something supernatural something
abnormal within the normal world within
this world these peculiar beings are
only able to stay hidden from the norm
in a time loop which is basically one
day just repeated over and over and over
again don't worry I'm not gonna spoil
anything for you I just want you to get
a gist of what it's all about
and the story follows this protagonist
called Jacob Portman who doesn't believe
that he's peculiar however his granddad
has been telling him for curious stories
all of his life so he decides to visit a
little island in Wales where he is about
to get his mind blown and find a time
loop and find these peculiar children
and find out that actually no spoilers
I'm gonna cut it there so I'm a girl I
as a lover of the original book by
ransom Riggs I had pretty high
expectations for this film and I wasn't
sure if it would reach those
expectations especially when I realized
that Emma's peculiarity of fire had been
changed with the elaborate efficient
ability and he gravity abilities were
whatever in his balloon ability however
after speaking to the cast and watching
the movie myself I'm actually very
happily surprised with what occurred
Ella gave a brilliant answer to why she
thought Tim Burton changed the
peculiarities around and I'll just put a
bit of that in now because she can say
better than I ever could who adapt a
book to a movie is incredibly difficult
you all know that and there's never the
same you all know that as well but I
think that it's almost a compliment to
the book that nobody's tried to exactly
replicate everything yeah things have
been changed for cinematic purposes and
and actually when you see it visually on
screen it's so lovely personally for an
access standpoint as well it gives me a
bigger storyline because if she's
already fiery what could she realize
about herself you know she's already
confident she's already brave but sadly
to start off a little bit heartbroken a
little bit down and then to sort of
realize your own strength and to get
over those trust issues until you can
love again and you are strong and you
are brave I mean that that's the kind of
journey that I'd like to that I wanted
to play and I wanted to show a cross on
screen overall I actually do really like
the fact that the film tries to be you
to the book it kept the essence of the
book the storyline the creepy pictures
and brought them to life which was the
best part because the pictures are the
best part of the book they are what draw
you into the story make it feel more
real and you actually got to see that
come to life on screen I've really
really enjoyed that I also white light
Enochs character because I'm quite a
dark person myself and just the thought
of being able to make little creations
and bring them life is slightly
disturbing yet extremely exciting to me
and I felt that he pulled it off very
well you know you're pretty much like
the middle dr. Frankenstein yeah I love
love love the scene where you first get
to see him bring his toys to light don't
worry no spoilers but is an amazing
scene using a pretty short stop-motion
and I loved that it reminded me of Tim
Burton's old style of Nightmare Before
Christmas kind of animation stop-motion
vibe it was great I would love to see
him do more of that please do more of
that Tim that was so good
I enjoyed that anyway these are my
thoughts on the film please do check out
the interview I am still mind-blowing
that I got this opportunity it was just
so lovely to meet such talented actors
and actresses overall I'm very pleased
with how the film turned out the book
it's still astounding and you can't make
a perfect replication of the book to the
film so for what it is I think it's
worth to see someone saying have a
lovely day or evening they why did I do
that I think the last book I read miss
peregrine's home for peculiar children
but like number two the book number two
a camera for that was called and then I
liked the little comic book that came
with a Batman game that was pretty cool
we 88/100 says what are your favorite
movies my favorite movie still the same
as my last you la is submarine